jafar abdul karim's first book examines  issues facing germany's arab community  from the perspective of a mediator  between two worlds  that's nothing new for the deutsche  welle journalist in the last 10 years  karim has covered issues such as female  genital mutilation forced marriage and  so-called honor killings  he's often reported from arab and  african countries including crisis  regions  every week kareem and his team produce  the socially critical youth show  shabab talk reaching an audience of  millions in arab countries  his book strangers or friends will first  be published in german  it describes his encounters as a  reporter in other countries  and with people from arab countries who  now live in germany  the book also highlights his own  experience as an arab-born journalist  who feels very much at home in berlin